info intox avec anthony st léger bonjour
bonjour si on s'arrête ce soit en inde
où l'interdiction du hidjab dans les
écoles a déclenché des manifestations et
nourrit les fausses informations oui à
deux modes contexte assez a rapidement
tout est parti de manifestations fin
décembre début janvier dans un lycée du
district doudou pisser dans l'état du
karnataka dans le sud ouest on va voir
une carte des étudiantes ont dénoncé
l'interdiction qui leur était faite par
leur établissement de porter le voile
dans les salles de cours depuis d'autres
écoles ont suivi le mouvement de
protestation qui a pris de l'ampleur et
notamment depuis la semaine dernière et
a entraîné des tensions entre musulmans
et hindous et quoi de mieux pour attiser
les tensions que justement d un fox
partager sur les réseaux sociaux vient
la première c'est celle ci regardez
cette vidéo qui est publié ici via un
tweet du 9 février est dernier près de
49000 du via ce tweet que nous dit ce
tweet alors on voit justement que cette
vidéo cette femme apparemment enceinte
en hidjab est en fait arrêter par des
policiers est en fait un homme qui cache
des marchandises sous le hidjab alors
que nous dit le tweet en question il
nous dit voilà une raison plus
d'interdire la burqa et cette idée est
cette vidéo on la voit ait circulé aussi
dans plusieurs publications que ce soit
en anglais ou encore en hindi cette
vidéo en quoi est ce une intro et bien
tout simplement parce que nous ne sommes
pas en inde d'abord mais on est au
bangladesh et c'est une recherche
d'image inversé comme souvent qui nous
met sur la piste et on retourne par
exemple sur cette vidéo youtube en
version au plus long qui date du 10 mars
2021 et voilà la version plus longue de
la scène en question cette arrestation
elle est bien celle d'un homme déguisé
en femme en simple mais pour trafic de
drogue voilà pourquoi il a été arrêté ce
qui est cash s'est caché sous le lit
jobs ce n'est pas facile et c'est
justement de la drogue on est à
chittagong c'est au sud donc du
bangladesh voici pour la carte et cette
histoire on la retrouve aussi dans des
médias locaux qui ont fait écho
justement de l'histoire et on notera
d'ailleurs un petit détail mais que les
policiers de la vidéo on porte bien
l'uniforme de la police bangladaise que
l'on voit ici à gauche en bleu alors que
policiers indiens ont le l'uniforme
plutôt beige rien à voir donc
une autre vidéo elle est aussi
décontextualisés elle s'inspire des
manifestations en inde oui des images
que voici regardez on va les découvrir
ensemble on voit de nombreuses femmes
qui pour certaines ont le hidjab se
faire jeter de l'eau des seaux d'eau en
l'occurrence par des hommes il a cette
vidéo elle est partagée ici en anglais 1
le 9 février par ce compte twitter on la
retrouve ailleurs ce compte twitter il
nous dit quoi il mentionne les valeurs
morales déclinant de la bbp c'est une
association étudiante la bvb
d'inspiration nationaliste et il nous
dit donc que il revendique ce droit à
porter le hidjab via des hashtags
notamment alors pourquoi est-ce une un
fox là encore c'est une recherche
d'image inversée qui nous aide qui donne
comme première occurrence cette page
facebook où on retrouve la vidéo ici
dans un autre format mais c'est
exactement la même cette vidéo vous le
voyez cette publication facebook pardon
elle date du 23 février 2019 la scène
s'est déroulée à l'université de l'est
et on est au sri lanka donc à rien à
voir avec l'inde et des recherches
complémentaires nous mène au site
d'information putty tout un site que
gère des sri lanka à l'étranger et un
article de novembre 2019 dans lequel des
étudiants de cette université ont été
interrogés nous raconte que c'est un
bizutage étudiants rien à voir donc avec
les manifestations en inde actuellement
on reste en inde pour terminer avec une
image de circonstance c'est la saint
valentin raphaël ça ne vous a pas
échappé quoi de plus adéquat que de
partager des images de coeur sur les
réseaux sociaux en voici un exemple
cette île en forme de coeur mais info ou
intox et bien info et intox intox
d'abord parce que cette photo c'est une
création artistique notamment de ce
compte instagram mes infos aussi parce
que c'est une photo retouchée à partir
d'une île qui existe réellement en
l'occurrence celle ci alors on autres et
que le père est beaucoup moins évident
on note la retouche quand même on est
dans le sud ouest de l'inde dans les
eaux cavalli on peut aussi voir un
visage oui je trouve que ça limite ça
ressemble plus à une citrouille qu'à une
quinqua ses persos visage d'arcimboldo
pas merci anthony s'alléger c'était info
intox rester avec nous on se retrouve
dans aller un peu plus de trois minutes
pour un nouveau jeu paris
[Musique]